the reason why frodo gets as far as he
does with the ring and then how sam
really helps him out i think
specifically is due to the fact that
they are hobbits and they don't get
as affected by the ring as other
creatures would so i think mary and
pippin would do quite well there's an
inkling in certainly in the books
that frodo has a little bit of elven
kind of influence in his genealogy would
that be the right word family tree
really some some
elven ways
and that maybe he's the perfect
candidate for that but i still think
that mary and pippen would do a good job
i think we did brilliant and i think
we'd get it there faster and i think
there would be more laughs
and uh yeah i'd say we'd be better i
think we'd be better and also i think
we'd find things on the way like you
know a tree
that um that grows orange juice or
something and also mushrooms would find
a lot of mushrooms
so that would make it more interesting
wouldn't it
[Music]
nice with me and hold me down
[Music]